emblème monsieur l'antenne bonsoir
bonjour bonjour on est en plein cœur de
l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine docteur Michaud
bonjour
avant Noël
je vois une dépêche arriver
le don le plus important fait pour une
fondation d'un hôpital
40 millions de dollars en engagement
ferme de 40 millions de dollars et c'est
vous qui avez fait ça pourquoi question
toute simple
j'ai eu un fils qui s'appelait Benoît
qui est décédé de la leucémie en 1989 on
n'a pas eu d'enfants ensemble puis on
n'avait pas d'autres enfants Benoît est
un enfant
unique et
pensez toujours dit que bon si on se
faisait frapper par un camion que tous
les deux qu'on laissait ça un organisme
de charité Benoît était traitée à
l'Hôpital de Montréal pour enfants et
c'est comme ça c'est une c'est une
démarche de plusieurs années et on a
décidé de mettre nos économies communes
ensemble pour favoriser
recherche et vous avez fait des
recherches justement avant de choisir
cette justice vous dites il a été traité
Benoît à l'Hôpital de Montréal pour
enfants vous auriez pu aller là oui vous
avez regardé attentivement il fallait
que ça soit
utile
oui bien on est allé à l'hôpital
Montréal pour enfants puis à l'hôpital
juif et à saint-justice
qu'on avait décidé tous les deux de
rencontrer et pour leur parler de ce
qu'on voulait faire et on a demandé on a
regardé avec eux des projets de
recherche et ça a été par la suite ça a
été déchirant déchirant particulier pour
moi là finalement on a choisi Sainte
Justine et vous vous êtes dit j'imagine
vous êtes des comptables vous êtes dit
c'est mieux d'aider un avec beaucoup
d'argent que 3 4 avec moins d'argent oui
ça c'est un raisonnement qu'on a fait
dès le départ pour avoir le maximum
d'impact donc un levier comment un
Blaire c'est important que ces gens-là
servent à quelque chose oui parce que si
on va avoir un impact on ne peut pas
s'éparpiller on a fait des recherches
nous-mêmes là où il y avait des besoins
on s'est rendu compte que même après
tant d'années qu'il y avait encore
plutôt
d'enfants qui
mourrait du cancer alors on voulait
vraiment on a rapidement décidé que ça
allait être pour les enfants
l'oncologie parce que ça ne touchait
plus directement et avec un montant
comme ça les projets vont être docteur
Michaud pourra vous en parler vont être
plus pointus et on va pouvoir voir c'est
ce qu'on veut de notre vivant c'est ce
qu'on voulait des résultats de notre
vivant docteur Michaud bonjour donc
est-ce que ça fait une réelle différence
dans vos projets de recherche
l'argent qui arrive comme ça va
transformer ce qu'on va pouvoir offrir à
saint-justice au cours des prochaines
années
la recherche a permis de faire diminuer
le taux de mortalité de 110 % début des
années 80 amenant 20% mais on peine à
franchir ce seuil de 20%, et parce qu'il
y a un groupe de cancers qui résiste à
nos traitements donc on a besoin de
changer notre façon de faire d'avoir des
nouvelles stratégies thérapeutiques puis
une opportunité à saisir qui est celle
des nouvelles technologies soit la
génomiques la capacité de modifier les
cellules souches d'éditer le génome de
l'intelligence artificielle pour
identifier les nouvelles molécules
actives contre les cancers mais ces
approches-là coûte cher et des besoins
sont énormes donc c'est vraiment là où
la philanthropie va nous permettre de de
de les saisir ces opportunités pour
viser à offrir ces nouveaux traitements
donc à terme le parce que vous c'est 40
millions à terme il va avoir des
versements c'est pas un chèque de 40
millions les gens ont compris mais c'est
à terme
cette portion-là pour vous et
significative ah oui c'est majeur ça
nous permettent de
d'explorer des idées que nous
chercherons sans recourir de rapidement
sans recourir à des financements
externes ça va nous donner une
flexibilité pour vraiment passer à une
autre vitesse et vraiment développer
cette nouvelle génération de traitement
je m'imagine que Monsieur l'antenne et
Madame Blaise vous avez demandé dans la
démarche est-ce que ce qu'on va donner
va sauver des enfants
ultimement
la question que je posais quand allons
nous voir le premier enfant pas tous les
enfants on sait qu'on va s'ouvre pas
tous les enfants mais quand allons nous
voir le premier enfant qui va bénéficier
du fruit de notre investissement dans la
recherche ça c'est une question qu'on a
posé constamment aux trois hôpitaux et
puis c'est vraiment possible voilà
réforme mais je pense qu'on est assez
optimiste qu'on aura un impact on a déjà
des projets
de développement thérapie qui sont dans
le pipeline donc ce qui se rapproche de
l'essai clinique puis de de du chevet du
des enfants mais aussi on veut que le
fond fasse émerger les nouvelles idées
parce qu'il faut avoir une longue vue
donc donc parce qu'on a déjà des pas mal
de projets qui sont déjà assez avancés
on pense que le fond va nous permettre
de rendre concrète concrétiser plus
rapidement encore et puis mais on veut
aussi que le fond investi dans l'avenir
aussi donc falloir doser ça avoir un
impact à court terme en même temps
s'assurer qu'on aura un impact va
continuer dans le temps et peut-être
aussi l'aliment important c'est que ce
qui est important pour le Québec c'est
que c'est quand on développe des
nouvelles thérapies au Québec mais ça
accélère l'accès pour les enfants du
Québec si la thérapie développée à
Philadelphie c'est des enfants
philosophiques en bénéficiant en
première ligne donc je pense que c'est
un élément important du fond c'est de
d'accélérer l'accès ces nouvelles
thérapies là pour l'ensemble des enfants
québécois vous dites il y a 20% donc
deux enfants sur 10 qui va qui qui va
encore c'est comme s'il y avait un mur
là est-ce que c'est ce dernier
petit à sauver c'est ce qui est le plus
difficile c'est le plus difficile donc
ça c'est un vrai défi puis on réalise
qu'il faut changer de façon de faire
comme je mentionnais mais l'autre défi
aussi c'est celui des effets secondaires
c'est à dire que les traitements qu'on a
actuellement qu'on dispose actuellement
peuvent être efficaces mais trop souvent
cause des effets secondaires sérieux à
court moyen ou long terme et donc ce
double défilent
parlez-moi madame blême monsieur
l'antenne de de ce geste là vous avez
fait par rapport à d'autres que font des
Très Riches parce que ce qui a surpris
c'est que le montant est plus gros que
des gens qui ont encore une plus grosse
fortune que vous là est-ce que ceux qui
ont beaucoup beaucoup d'argent devraient
vous penser suivre votre
[Rires]
expire on les inspire et que d'autres
gens vont suivre cet exemple là
d'ailleurs on a on relance nos amis
notre réseau
et tranquillement on sent que l'idée
fait son chemin je pense que ce que les
gens
pourtant c'est pas c'est pas la fin du
monde mais ce qu'ils ont
retenus dans notre approche c'est notre
désir de voir de notre vivant des
résultats et ça ça a touché bien des
gens puis on l'espère que
l'exemple sera suivi effectivement parce
que c'est pas juste une fois que vous
serez décédé là c'est maintenant que les
chakras oui oui oui
au moment du décès puis 40 millions nous
on voulait participer à tout ça le voir
puis voir ce premier enfant comme je
l'ai disais tantôt c'était juste
mentionné donc clairement madame Blais
monsieur en tant que veulent qu'on leur
donne fasse une différence puis le
message est bien reçu puis on va faire
pour que ça soit le cas mais c'est un
don pour le 40 millions c'est pour la
recherche quand on est devant un enfant
dont on sait pas qu'on comment qu'on
sait pas comment traiter quand on sait
plus trop ce qu'on fait ben on se
retourne vers la recherche puis donc
c'est-à-dire retour
l'enfant l'adolescent et la recherche et
absolument critique pour amener les
soins à un autre niveau donc c'est
vraiment essentiel pour transformer les
soins et améliorer ce qu'on fait et ça
fait partie des soins c'est pas quelque
chose qui a pensé intégré c'est vraiment
un stage important
on n'irait pas sur la Lune on avancerait
pas justement on verra le nom de votre
fils en fait le fond on s'appelle Benoît
lantaigne et le il y a un centre va
s'appeler Benoît Lanta ici est-ce que
pour vous c'est transformé une
nouvelle tragique quelque chose de beau
je n'ai jamais été capable d'entendre ça
c'est un geste positif quand on
pose je comprends ça mais il y a rien de
beau dans la mort d'un enfant là j'ai
jamais moi c'est moi c'est personnel je
n'ai jamais été capable de
d'entendre ça ou d'accepter ça c'est par
contre ça donne une deuxième vie à
Benoît benoît va être là ça va être un
petit modèle pour les enfants et ça a
donné aussi une certaine sérénité à
Michel oui beaucoup de voir ça oui ce
geste là cette révolte là que vous avez
eu lorsqu'il est décédé la révolte vous
en êtes servis positivement vous oui oui
si on veut par amour par mot pour mon
fils la révolte
mais pour en venir au centre Diane et
moi on ne pensait pas de mettre le nom
de Benoît aucun endroit c'est venu ce
sont les fondations qui nous ont offert
ça là
mais ce qu'il y a de magique ici c'est
que le centre Benoît d'antenne ça va
être écrit c'est juste en avant du
Collège Brébeuf
plein d'enfants et quand je suis revenu
à Sainte-Justine ça m'a tellement frappé
moi je sais ce que c'est qu'un hôpital
pédiatrique je sais ce que c'est rentré
là-dedans je suis rentré pendant cinq
ans avec mon fils à l'Hôpital de
Montréal pour enfants puis là vous avez
des enfants qui se battent pour leur vie
puis en avant
l'autre côté de la rue ça criait sa joie
on était venu sur l'heure du midi les
enfants c'était l'heure du lunch ça
jouait au ballon et vous avez les deux
mondes là c'est
moi ça m'a frappé ça m'a touché
profondément
parce que la vie continue aussi la vie
continue il faut qu'elle continue pour
ses enfants
merci beaucoup bonne suite docteur
Michaud vous avez de la pression là
on est content d'en avoir
merci beaucoup à vous trois merci merci